hey I'm Kurt and I play the resident
before remake
I only played it for 30 minutes I can
say one thing is for sure that this
could be the resident 4 remake fans want
but not the one they're expecting to get
and this can all be illustrated by a
single choice that Capcom made with a
dog and if you know the dog you know the
dog you know what dog
the demo kicks off in the opening
moments where Leon S Kennedy is hot on
the trail to investigate The
Disappearance of the president's
daughter and while it all feels familiar
to the events of the original do not be
fooled because this Resident Evil 4 is a
lot more menacing than returning players
might expect this time around Leon is
trudging through a moonlit forest and
the sense of impending dread is on Full
display the sound of buzzing flies the
squawks of crows and the rotting mound
of animal carcasses stacked along the
path emphasizes the more horror-centric
tone
now I don't want to reveal too many
details about the opening Shack scene
because I want returning fans to be
surprised but I will say that it
unravels a little differently and it's
absolutely terrifying it subverted my
expectations of the iconic first ganondo
and though subtle the change was enough
for me to start questioning what would
happen around every corner
I was forced to navigate its many
hallways and rooms which felt more
maze-like and to my surprise featured
locked doors that required keys to open
it's a small detail but one that further
sets it apart from the original making
it more akin to traditional Resident
Evil design which the original resin 4
strayed away from the shack felt grimy
disgusting and dilapidated and this all
came to a head with a harrowing first
run-in with the Resident Evil 4 remix
take on the ganondo
with only one ammo clip at my disposal
cornered and trapped I alternated firing
off rounds and desperately fending it
off using my knife which unlike the
original has a durability bar gennados
were revolutionary in the original for
their distinct movements like ducking
out of the way of your Crosshair or
holding their hands in front of their
face to block shots we've come a long
way since then but it's safe to say that
the frenetic characteristics have been
turned up a notch to ensure they're
still a threat
up close their faces are contorted and
grimacing and being grabbed by one
offers a chance to get a little intimate
with the details
like before aiming for the knees will
prompt enemies to fall to the ground
cueing up a prompt to kick their face in
for a knockback effect on the
surrounding villagers and as expected it
felt incredibly cool because Leon is in
fact a very cool dude something new to
the mix were executions sometimes after
Downing a gonado there was an invitation
to press R2 making Leon plunge his knife
into the target sprinting through the
woods I can hear groans and murmurs from
villagers in the distance really giving
the sensation of being surrounded on all
sides and if my anxiety wasn't high
enough that's when I came across the dog
in this Resident Evil 4 there is no dog
to save from a bear trap and instead a
murder of crows surrounded its corpse
leg still trapped the message was clear
this Resident Evil 4 is darker and even
more dire than the one you know
through all its subtle changes one thing
remained near identical The Village
scene this was to me a shining moment
that Capcom knows not to fix because it
certainly ain't Brook instead the
remarkable difference is the
introduction of stealth this time Leon
can Crouch and move around creating the
opportunity to silently pick off enemies
and gather resources but don't be fooled
the Rampage of villagers hunting you
down is still inevitable the moment
you're spotted is a white knuckled
Sprint to stay alive as you are
surrounded on all sides I scrambled
through doors jumped through Windows
avoided dozens of gonados that lurched
at me or threw hatchets from all angles
I'd pop one of the knees kicking into
the crowd only to be grabbed from behind
triggering a Parry attack to plunge my
knife into their face while ammo was
scarce materials to make weren't either
scavenged through drawers to find
supplies to craft ammunition and health
items another design Trope carried over
from the broader series and through the
chaos and frantic control troller
crunching Leon still managed to toss out
one-liners at a much needed levity with
a casual feel me for the repairs later
Leon you just set an innocent cow on
fire dude how are you this cool the
chaos I was so familiar with from the
original was turn up to 11 this time
around the way the gennados now move
bump into each other and scramble to
tear you apart with their bare hands is
only topped in intensity by the menacing
presence of the Chainsaw man
who now smashes through the environment
to get to you
adding an extra maniacal presence to an
already high stress situation when the
demo ended I could still feel my heart
pounding through my chest
a major takeaway was the emphasis on
Survival horror specifically now this is
interesting because the original made
such a distinction away from its
survival horror Roots only for the
Remake to reaffirm it now it seems like
Capcom is making a very deliberate
effort to try and balance action and
survival I'm of course I'm eager to see
if they can really pull it off Resident
Evil 4 remake doesn't feel like it's
aiming to revolutionize games the way
the original did 17 years ago instead
Capcom is doubling down on what has made
Verizon before Timeless all these years
later its design its tension and of
course Leon S Kennedy in doing so its
goal is to emphasize what remains great
while fine-tuning it with everything the
franchise has learned in its 26 years of
existence
so far it feels like Capcom knows what
it needs to add an order for this game
to stand on its own especially among a
new generation of horror games not to
mention a plethora of remakes that we
have coming out of the way including
Dead Space alone in the dark and now
Silent Hill 2. but from what I can tell
Capcom knows what it needs to add in
order to please returning Fanatics like
me and yes the Bingo line
it's there